ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen nicht mehr allzu
süßen minecraft hält meine lieben
freunde dann alle unter euch die letzte
episode minecraft mit luca nicht gesehen
haben
da ist einiges passiert es hat ein
überfall stattgefunden auf unsere kleine
insel hier stimmt wachen schwebt das
scheiße in der letzten episode wurde
meine insel hier komplett verwüstet und
ihr seht schon an vielen stellen dass
bäume beschädigt wurden teilweise
komplett abgetragen wurden oder so wie
ich hier einfach nur noch verwüstete
aussehen sieht ganz einfach daran weil
in der letzten episode ein überfall
stattgefunden hat auf meine kleine insel
hier ich war ja vor zwei folgen in einer
kleinen kampf situation wo ich bei einem
außenposten von siedlern heißt unser
glaube ich ein bisschen krawall gemacht
habe und ich dachte wir sind ja auch
selbst schuld wenn ich da hin bauen auf
jeden fall waren diese räuber dann nicht
so glücklich darüber dass ich die ein
bisschen auseinander genommen habe und
dann haben sie sich gedacht als
rachefeldzug greifen wir einfach lukas
kleine insel an und das musste ich in
kauf nehme ich bin dabei auf beschreiben
und er hoffe ich jetzt mal dass wir
quitt sind ihr seht auch schon ich baue
hier gerade nebenbei alles mal so ein
bisschen ab weil ich bin ganz ehrlich
ich möchte jetzt nicht irgendwelche
halbgaren bäume hier stehen lassen und
mit glaubt dann irgendwie wieder
auffrischen und dann ist das so ein
bisschen so wie wenn man sich kunstrasen
in seinen garten pack das ist nichts
halbes und nichts ganzes klar sieht
damit das schön aus und so wie vorher
und man muss sich nicht groß drum
kümmern
aber es geht mir um die natur und ich
finde gerade so als würde ich hier
überall einen vortrag halten vor frei
der future oder so das ist minecraft
luca war die kirche mit dem ball flach
mein ziel für die heutige episode
minecraft mit luca ist es auf jeden fall
dass unsere ebenso wieder schön wird es
wird wenn jetzt so möchte eine insel
reparatur 3.0 warum ist hier vorne weg
fahren die das auch noch gott na ja ich
bin's tut mir leid dass ich dann
vielleicht mal so ein bisschen
überdramatisiert wirke und ein bisschen
zu emotional aber so kleinigkeiten neben
den zerbrechlichen luca dann auch schon
oft mal ein bisschen mit muss ich auch
sagen und vor allem wenn man über 30
folgen lange dieser insel gearbeitet hat
dann urplötzlich blöcke abgebaut werden
bäume aus den wurzeln gerissen werden
dann schlägt das bei mir gebrechlichen
menschen ein bisschen aufs herz und
daher tut mir auch leid dass ich
vielleicht ein bisschen überreagiert in
der letzten episode
allerdings soll es darum heute nicht
mehr gehen sondern wir bauen hier alles
neu auf ihr seht schon ich habe gerade
den bau wie mit der schaukel abgebaut
was helfern das ist ja der witz moment
sie gewiss hier bist und den hatten wir
bereits das ist immer noch nicht lustig
allerdings wenn ich auf das man bauen
das war nämlich vorher glaube ich noch
weiß das schon
[Musik]
es ist auch ihnen pilz er hier bleibt
auf jeden fall stehen der hat ja schon
kult mittlerweile in diesem projekt hier
der dings vor der luke uwe fehlt seit
folgen da wird aber weil direkt alles
hier stehen und liegen gelassen guck mal
hier freunde alter ist ja auch alles
hier kaputt gemacht worden
der loop den habe ich ja seinen folgen
nicht mehr wieder aufgebaut hast ich
denn für ein idiot
er forderte aber auch noch mal eben auf
die sache ist da musste ich hier auch
immer so ein bisschen geht davon nicht
auch der bogen kaputt wenn ich hier zur
sachen abbaue
ich weiß es nicht einfach mal die
ofenkartoffeln
[Musik]
hat jetzt gerade gesagt
allerdings stehen nicht nur die tiere
auf meiner seite sondern auch ihr was
dieser ganze überfall situation hier
angehen denn die kommentare waren
wirklich voll mit positiven feedback von
euch die marien hier über trinkst hier
also nee du erstickt
ja was machen denn tiere die eigentlich
im wasser leben dann an land
na gut dann immer weiter da vorne wir
was wir drehen uns jetzt auf jeden fall
hier wieder auf dem wiederaufbau und da
an der stelle wie bereits schon
angedeutet ganz kurz noch mal ein
riesiges dankeschön an euch für euren
extreme geisteskranken support wir waren
in den deutschen youtube trend jedoch
platz 4 oder so das kann ich immer noch
nicht handeln dass jede folge so krass
bei euch ankommt hat immer die gleichen
16 gebraucht doch noch denn ich werde
mir so ein paar verschiedene bäume hier
auch meine insel hauen oder andere
probierten den toten wunsch kann ich
auch endlich mal mitnehmen und auch
meinen ton ich weiß nicht wo ich denn
hin gepackt hatte ich vorne war der hier
vorne einfach mal in den ofen hauen so
dass wir uns auch die blumentöpfe freude
machen können und ich würde allerdings
erst mal sagen ich lasse mir schon mehr
viel stress ablenken
danke auf jeden fall für ein riesiges
feedback ich suche mir die setzlinge
raus und kurze tipps für euch jetzt hier
dann an der stelle weltfrieden
so meine lieben freund ich hab da mal so
ein bisschen items sortiert da war er in
der letzten folge noch nicht so richtig
die zeit für weil ich ja dann doch sehr
emotional war über die ganze situation
hier mit meiner insel
ihr seht schon unten ich hab den weizen
farbstoffe in der hand und möchte aber
dass es falsch war
hey wie süß ist erst kürzlich wieder
voll auf meiner seite ist seitdem jetzt
die situation mit dem überfall hatten
naja ich werde erstmal auch ganz gut
hier nochmal das knochenmehl nehmen und
hier alles ein bisschen schöner machen
plus
ich möchte heute jetzt auch das ja nur
ein bisschen insel reparatur auch
richtig schreibt jetzt nicht im titel
weil dann ist bin ich mal so sie nicht
dann fühle ich mich immer so gezwungen
mich so komplett krass darum zu kümmern
weil nach der ersten die reparatur folge
viele meinen höher also fast gar nichts
repariert von daher ganz kleinen
gewählte titel von mir wir reparieren
unsere inseln oder wir holen die ich
hier keine ahnung wie ich das video
nennen werde ich möchte auf jeden fall
mal ganz kurz das schweinchen hier
wieder weiß färben
geht jetzt nicht ich brauche nicht wolle
ihr fragt euch jetzt wahrscheinlich kuka
wofür brauchst du denn die weiße wolle
ich möchte mir teppiche machen und muss
die werkbank einer ladung habe ich die
werkbank ja damals da stehen gelassen
habe wo ich auf das ozean moment
gewartet habe beziehungsweise das ocr
moment rein wollte ich brauche auf jeden
fall erstmal hier vor ein bisschen
teppich und hiervon brauche ich auch
noch drei teppiche denn ich habe mir
auch schon dass hier mitgenommen
eichenholz zäune und ihr seht auch
bereits aktien setzlinge und knochenmehl
der ein oder andere erfahrene minecraft
spieler ab weiß dass ich erst
schlafengehen sollte weil ich sonst
wieder von krippen in die luft gejagt
werden der ein oder andere erfahrene
mannschaft spieler weiß direkt schon was
ich vorhabe und zwar möchte ich hier
freunde kann ich das ja nicht mal machen
einen baum hinsetzen jetzt hab ich
natürlich wieder keine er damit ich
idiot
ich will mal ganz kurz ihren block 17
hierhin ich ja so schön und mit ganz
viel glück dass häufig was ist das das
soll das ist ein fisch das ist da ist
mein boot mit ganz viel glück und das
möchte ich so ein bisschen erzwingen
geht der cardigan baum hier so rüber zu
extrem geil von der gruppe das hinkriegt
und er meint das ist das ist fast so
lang wie man wolle man beim anzünden ein
paar sekunden später
ich liebe dieses projekt wir
konzentrieren uns nicht mehr auf diesen
brennenden baum nach vorne warum brennt
ihr ziel
das geht aber nicht rüber oder du bist
in der schildkröte du kannst nicht
brennen
das kann ich doch zeigen kommen hier
feuerzeug auf die schildkröte
[Musik]
warum brennt denn mein strand hier jetzt
ab was sollen das ding soll und nicht
na ja das klingt ja eine ganze apparat
schon sehr ein ich würde sagen sie
konzentrieren sich auf den boden damit
hier wieder alles so ein bisschen
verbuchte aussieht mir auch immer viele
geschrieben luca doch gar nicht so schön
aus wenn da so viel gras ist doch das
ist gut
also bitte nicht aus dem konzept sind
jetzt die aussage
guck mal da müssen wir auch die tage
dann weiterbauen freue ich mich auch
schon darauf komme da hinten alles so
einen leichten nebel gehüllt hier soll
er die tiere insel hin hier vorne das
sollte die blumeninsel werden die wieder
runter ziehen aber das ist nicht das
thema für heute denn wir möchten heute
alles ein bisschen schöner machen
perfekt danke mal richtig dass wir
können eigentlich wieder da hinten
laufen
ich habe zu beginn des heutigen videos
auch hinten schon die fackeln entfernt
da wollte ich eigentlich sagen warum ich
das gemacht habe denn ich möchte auch in
der heutigen folge bands schon wie
der insel reparatur ist alles so ein
bisschen durch steinmauern ersetzen so
dass warum wächst du nicht sag mal was
sagt ein kleiner stift in groß halten um
maximal ich weiß nicht ob wir damit
zufrieden sind aber ich das sind einfach
mal stehen und werde mich jetzt auf das
konzentrieren was ich etwas sagen wollte
bleib beim thema ich hab's vergessen ich
sitze hier erst mal wirken baum hin und
da ein bisschen knochenmehl drauf denn
ich benötige ein bisschen birkenholz für
eine kleine strandliegen und strand
sonnenschirm situation die hier vorne
stattfinden soll deswegen wollte
eigentlich dass der so ein bisschen
übers wasser drüber geht da der das
jetzt nicht gemacht hat ist das
vielleicht aber auch ganz gut weil man
sich dann hier vorne hinlegen kann
sondern wird hier nicht weiß dass so
strand liegen und vor allem sonne strand
schirm sonnenschirm dingsbums teams
hätte doch das sams ganz schweres ding
gewesen ich weiß dass das eigentlich
tendenziell eher mehr sinn macht bei
unserer komischen strandnähe komisch ist
nicht sehr modern und sehr schön
ich glaube dass sich viele denken dass
es eigentlich dort mehr sinn macht die
sache ist allerdings dass ich da dass
ich das hier machen will
ich weiß nämlich dass unsere wieder da
hinten noch ein bisschen dauern wird von
daher möchte ich jetzt erstmal ganz kurz
mir hier vorne sondern kleine liege
hinstellen und also ein bisschen schön
machen so dass wir nicht nur alles neu
aufbauen in der heutigen folge sondern
noch etwas hinzufügen
also hier solch kleine liege und dann
beispielsweise hier noch sonne mehr über
eck machen sondern bissig und so
vielleicht dass man hier dann so sitzen
kann und dann nehme ich mir jetzt meine
zäune und die teppiche denn ich möchte
so ein rot weißen
wir machen an mayonnaise und ketchup
angelehnt so helfe ich mal kurz hier
drauf und kann jetzt hier einfach den
teppich drauflegen und hier an die seite
und hier an die seite geht das nicht
gesehen haben wir noch kein mal wieder
getroffen sagt was das denn
[Musik]
das hat mich letztes schiller geburtstag
er hat sich aufgepumpt das war mist
[Musik]
ich lasse ihn ruhig lasst sie in ruhe
wir konzentrieren uns nicht auf lippe
oder irgendwas was im wasser jetzt habe
ich es vor dass schon schön aus es sieht
schon schön aus also ein bisschen übers
der wasserwehr vielleicht ein bisschen
noch schöner gewesen aber wir
konzentrieren uns erstmal hier drauf
denn ich glaube wirklich dass teppich
nicht in der luft schweben kann wenn
irgendwer von euch da wieder so pro
player tipps habt dann schreibt uns
gerne in die kommentare allerdings gehe
ich jetzt erstmal den weg dass ich das
ganze hier so bauer dann sitze ich hier
in hin
dann sitze ich noch hier vorne einen hin
dann setze ich noch ihr einen hin so und
noch hier von ihr fragte ich jetzt
wahrscheinlich sogar nach oben dass sie
überhaupt nicht gut aus jahr erwartet so
oder mache ich hier so dann kann ich
nämlich hier daran wiederum hat nämlich
abonniert hier vorne kommt dann noch
nicht wo hitzfeld wittern und hier auch
und dann hier vorne wieder gezeigt dann
gehen wir hier rüber und warum ich dich
heute gebaut hat weiß ich jetzt auch
nicht
also irgendwie es auch nicht alles
silber was gold glänzt er ganz komische
folge heute ist tut mir leid ich weiß
nicht wo meine letzte birkenholz falsch
ist allerdings muss ich mir dann wohl
zwangsläufig noch mal neu machen hier
vorne freibad sagt die eben eingesammelt
und je das ist schon schön aus so klar
da fehlt was aber von oben vielleicht
sieht man den roten teppich kann auch
kuba
dass ihr weg ist und so das ist schon
schön aus wenn wir hier noch so eine
kleine situation habe ich zur
plötzlichen goldener zickzack wir können
hier noch kommen das mache ich auch noch
eben alt
wir können das überhaupt nicht um die
insel reparatur sondern nur meine neue
strandliege ich benötige für das was ich
vorhabe nochmal vier stück von denen
dann kann er direkt hier meinen ton
mitzunehmen bzw
kaka dann noch mal eben kurz müssen mehr
kohle rein ich hab einfach so viel
kohleblöcke das unfassbar ihr einer
sollte jahr reichen sagte er du wieder
zurück hier rein das gesetz voll im
stress
wir müssen auf jeden fall demnächst
irgendwann die ganze kiste sortierung
ein bisschen genauer unter die lupe
nehmen denn ich mache mir sogar noch
einen mehr glaube ich mach mit insgesamt
5 denn meine lieben freunde ich möchte
nicht mehr oben die ganzen kisten sachen
drin sondern da oben wirklich
entscheidend endlich entscheid mit
sondern verzaubert nicht verzaubern
sondern die heiß auf den verdrängten ist
mit diesen trinken möchte ich da auf
jeden fall machen und hier vor wie sexy
das da oben glitzert
[Musik]
ich möchte diesen raum hier komplett zu
einem kisten raum machen und ich glaube
das macht auch sinn denn dann hat mir da
oben alles so ein bisschen was frauen
angeht da möchte ich mir die mich in den
nächsten von generell ein bisschen mit
auseinandersetzen weil wir auch im
moment wollen dann haben die ganzen
kisten drin und wenn wir verzaubern
wollen können wir da hinten auf der
zauberinsel machen und dieses portal
hier wird auch in der nächsten folge
umgebaut wir haben nachts ein bisschen
das so schnell passiert als ich hasse es
komme auf jeden fall möchte ich hier
unten auch noch etwas raus machen hab
ich jetzt wahrscheinlich was heiko k
wenn wir irgendwie angegriffen werden
kann wir dann immer runter in unseren
schutz proben gegeben
von daher ist das auch noch steht das
auch noch offen offen stand und den
dingen warum bin ich denn jetzt hier
soll ich denn hier machen
ich wollte gar nichts machen ich wohl
schlafen gehen da ich in den zehn
minuten danach in dieser episode völlig
verteilt war wie mache ich euch einfach
ganz kurze time labs wie ich ein paar
bäume aufbaue wie ich meine liegen
situation noch ein bisschen schöner
bauer und wie ich erde abbaue allerdings
machen wir jetzt an dieser stelle weiter
[Musik]
warum
warum sind hier schon wieder diese
idioten sag bitte nicht das ist ich
lasst sie in ruhe
ich habe wir sind quitt die kommen rüber
die komm rüber zu mir warum den gottes
namen sind die noch hier ich habe die
besiegt die habe nicht getötet und dann
habe ich die besiegte sind sowas von kit
und jetzt sind die hier und schwimmen
zurück zu meiner insel warum das kann
doch nicht sein der überfall ist doch
vorbei wie kann das denn sein freund
schreibt mir bitte in die kommentare was
ich falsch gemacht habe und warum die
jetzt wieder hier bei mir sind aber ich
habe keinen bock mich mit ihnen zu
beschäftigen weil ich einfach nur meine
insel reparieren will ich verstehe es
nicht es kann doch nicht möglich sein
dass die hier wieder angeschwommen
kommen wo sind sie listet euch gerne auf
der insel ein macht heuer ding ich habe
einfach nur entspannt hier meine erde
geholt weil ich meine insel heute
reparieren möchte nicht will keinen
stress allerdings ist jetzt erstmal das
aufgestockte ihr seht hier unten da ist
kein sand block mehr da irgendwie störte
eine optik hier vorne das muss halt
erstmal zu gras werden dann kann ich da
den dings normal weitermachen den weg
allerdings würde ich sagen dass wir erst
mal ganz kurz pending partie komisch
dass hier alles aussieht
die ganzen bäume nicht mehr stehen ich
fühle mich so kahl irgendwie auf der
ganzen insel na ja ach guck mal wieder
neue wolle bekommen das ist er noch mal
ganz kurz mitnehmen und hier vorne ja
das müssen wir alles demnächst einmal
abarbeiten ich sehe schon kommen dass
der schwarze brad voller wird unsere
ganze insel zusammen allerdings möchte
ich mich jetzt wirklich auf das
konzentrieren final hier zum ende der
folge was sie angehen wollten guck mal
wie leergefegt das aus ich weiß wir
wollten dass das die insel ein bisschen
weniger bäume hatte allerdings finde ich
das sehr schön wenn wir so ein bisschen
natur hier haben den baum hier vorne
gehen lasse ich einfach mal so dass ein
bisschen von ihr eigentlich sogar weil
das ja der witz baum ist dann kommt das
eigentlich relativ gut hin die an der
seite fehlten blatt das heißt das werde
ich hier an der seite sogar dann auch
nochmal immer abnehmen und hier vorne
auch so dass schaaf hat auf jeden fall
auch abgenommen wir konzentrieren uns
jetzt mal darauf dass wir hier die bäume
ein bisschen hoch kriegen
ich werde hier fordert dann wenn man so
eine fichte hinsetzen ich weiß nicht wie
das aussehen wird und ob eine fichte
wirklich auf unsere insel passt
allerdings der ihr zwei idioten glaubt
mir da hinten quartz blöcke ich würde
eigentlich sagen jetzt ist krieg aber
ich habe hier keine motivation wieder
fliegenden streit ich würde mich jetzt
erstmal wissen aufzubauen konzentrieren
der sieht auf jeden fall sehr schön aus
hier vorne sehe ich eine birk er
eigentlich die können wir hier auch sehr
schön da nehme ich noch ganz kurz die
teiche da können wir hier vorne nach
eichel hinsetzen so hier so ein bisschen
und auch schön aus kader schaaf hat
schon wieder alter der vermehrt sich ja
wie ein fisch auf dem dings laufen den
großen baum ja nicht stehen lassen jetzt
habe ich inzwischen auch so ein bisschen
blick hinter noch die tiere insel an
demnächst auch sehr schön noch eine
spinne guck mal einer an
hier vorne
[Musik]
ich habe draußen gerade dass ich dachte
jemand bord über mir und das ist ein duo
für die aufnahmen aber draußen sind die
kopten geflogen und in dem moment konnte
nie bei uns nichts da habe ich das war
[Musik]
ja alles wieder aufbauen
ja auch noch mal ganz kurzer time labs
wie ich den wasserfall wieder repariert
habe einige neue bäume gepflanzt habe
und generell die inseln bisschen
repariert habe doch jetzt geht's weiter
mit einer sehr traurigen situation was
ich auf jeden fall machen wollte weil
hier ganz kurz eben die blätter
wegpacken zack zack und tier das letzte
und ich wollte auch noch mal eben weil
hier beziehen schildkröten schön ja auch
hier drinnen rum
ich wollte ich schnappe die schildkröte
mit im boot wie kriege ich dann mein
boot heraus
[Musik]
co
kitzbühel und schildkröte
ich wollte eigentlich wollten um ein
boot zurück
[Musik]